thanks to great courses plus for
supporting pbs
hey hon what's this tiny deposit in our
savings account
oh that's the interest payment from our
new high yield savings account
are you sure it's only 42 cents how is
that high yield
are you kidding me the return on this
puppy is 16
times the national average we even had
to qualify for this special account type
but
takes money to make money am i right i
thought this was how we plan to pay for
our next
car by my math we'll hit our goal in
about 140 years
on the bright side by then we won't need
a car and our great great great
grandchildren can use it to get a
certified pre-owned teleporter instead
[Music]
finding a high yield place to park your
money these days
kind of makes me feel like i'm back in
middle school hunting for carmen san
diego
i see ads all the time for accounts
promising
high yields cash back and tempting
rewards
but as soon as i start sorting through
the clues as to where
these might be found the quarry seems to
slip through my fingers
whether it's a money market account cd
savings bond or even the old faithful
savings account finding one that pays
half a percent
is a struggle and if you do track a
halfway decent one down
there's always strings attached like
only for a certain amount of deposits or
only for a limited time
am i missing something see once upon a
time
safe secure deposits at a bank were a
pretty solid investment
in 1985 the year philip was born you
could purchase a
six-month certificate of deposit at your
local bank branch and earn
an average of 8.05
interest ah good old days right
sort of see banks were paying higher
interest rates
yes but they were also charging higher
interest rates too
the average rate on a 30-year fixed
mortgage in 1985
was a jaw-dropping 11.85
when you deposit your paycheck at a bank
or even put it in a savings vehicle like
a cd or savings account
it doesn't just sit there thanks to a
practice called
federal reserve banking banks can
actually lend
out 90 of your deposit and they do
in the forms of mortgage loans small
business loans and credit cards
any amount they charge above what they
pay you
is profit for them the difference
between the 1985 savings account and
mortgage rate
3.8 percent which is actually extremely
close to the difference today
because as the federal reserve raises or
lowers interest rates
it trickles down to everything so if the
difference between
bank deposits and bank loans are
relatively the same
now and then why does it matter what
your investment pays
one word inflation the amount of
interest you earn on bank deposits is
only
half the equation the other half is how
much the cost
of goods and services increases at the
same time
back in the mid 80s your six-month cd
would pay you about eight percent
and the prices of fanny packs and
bottles of new coke were increasing by
about
three percent this is what economists
call your
real return your investment return after
inflation
a five percent real return is nothing to
sniff at which explains why your
grandpappy might be bugging you about
setting up your savings account
investments like
savings bonds and even savings accounts
made perfect
sense decades ago but today with
inflation around two percent and
safe money paying close to zero you're
looking
at a negative real return suddenly
things like
savings accounts and cds seem like the
opposite of an investment
now before we get to what you've got to
do to earn a respectable
real return let's spare a moment for the
humble savings account
should you just toss the safe money
investment of yesteryear in the dumpster
along with those old
cd-roms and game boy cartridges no
they still have an important place but
that place has
changed savings accounts cds money
market accounts
aren't really a place to grow your money
and likely won't be
for the foreseeable future but these
accounts are the perfect place to stash
funds you expect to need in the short
term
think the next one to two years money to
pay
bills your emergency fund or cash for a
major purchase
are perfectly suited sure you can try to
spend hours sleuthing out the best high
yield savings accounts in every corner
of the internet
but the difference will be microscopic
and could change in a moment's notice
personally we've decided to just keep
all of our one-year money in a simple
checking account
crazy right but what about savings you
want to build up for the mid
or long term where does that belong the
reality is the only way to earn a
positive real return today
is going to involve some risk being a
crime fighting gum shoe
isn't a smooth ride all the time we're
not talking about
wild speculative risks like picking
individual stocks or betting on crypto
but something with mild variation in the
price over time
known as volatility financial planners
might refer to this as a
moderately conservative investment one
option to consider
is simply a bond index fund these
investments are generally backed by
guaranteed government and corporate
bonds
and they pay a respectable interest rate
at least more respectable than what your
bank account pays
one of the most popular bond index funds
has consistently grown between four
percent and five percent per year
over the last decade and while there is
some fluctuation in the price is
dramatically lower than the stock market
the volatility makes it inappropriate
for money you might need in the
immediate future
but could make sense for a goal a few
years out another
newly emerging option is peer-to-peer
lending platforms
that effectively allow you to be the
bank that's right
you can easily lend out your own money
to borrowers and
pocket some of the profit margin
yourself companies like
lending club prosper and funding circle
allow you to lend out your money to
consumers
hoping to avoid banks and you get paid
the interest
some pay you a flat interest rate like
five percent but you have to commit your
money for a year
others allow you to pick lenders with
higher or lower credit risk ratings
and pay anywhere from five percent to
the safest borrowers to
13 for the riskiest while these returns
may be enticing
it's important to remember that you run
the risk of paying penalties if you need
the money
before your term is over or your
borrower may default
leaving you with a loss the bad news is
that for millennials and gen z
the days of cash savings as a real
investment are long gone
the good news is that with some
strategic risk and a bit of research
you can still grow your money faster
than inflation without having to make
wild gambles
and that's our two cents thanks to great
courses plus for supporting pbs
the great courses plus is a subscription
on-demand video learning service with
lectures and courses from professors
from top universities and institutions
through your subscription you'll get
access to a library of lectures about
anything that interests you
science math history literature even how
to cook
play chess or become a better
photographer for example
games people play will teach you how to
apply the lessons of game theory to your
job
your business and your life to learn
more click on the link in the
description below to start your trial
today
thanks to our patrons for keeping two
cents financially healthy
click the link in the description to
become a two cents patron
to hear more about bonds and my sean
connery impression check out our video
bond savings bond
[Music]